oh hello there friends today we are
going to learn how to be a dictator
what kind of Frank Dakota is an author
and his most recent book how to be a
dictator looks at eight of the most
chillingly effective dictators of the
21st century so we're gonna learn about
Mussolini Hitler Stalin Mao Zedong Kim
il-sung and a couple of leaders that I'm
going to leave to Frank to pronounce but
yeah the characteristics of a dictator
oddly similar whilst also being
incredibly unique as Frank identifies
one dictator from one regime at one
particular period of time wouldn't work
at all if he was to swap places with
another as always if you've got any
questions comments or feedback feel free
to get at me at Kris will Ex wherever
you follow me but for now please welcome
Frank Dakota
[Music]
I am joined by Frank Dakota at the
beginning of his book tour Frank how are
you welcome to the show thank you thank
you for having me
that's a pleasure to have you on so
today you're going to teach us how to be
a dictator right that's the title of the
book not sure I can really help you go
all the way it's nice so it's not a
personal development self development
how to book it is probably more of a
history book that will tell you how to
spot other potential dictators good yeah
well if there are any budding dictators
in the in the audience today there might
be a little disappointed but for
everyone else those of us we're going to
be fascinated so tell us why you wrote
the book first off um well I'm a
historian and when you think about it
you could pretty much summarize the 20th
century in about a sentence there is an
attempt on the one hand to separate out
powers in other words to build up the
civil society to have checks and
balances that's a very difficult thing
to do
it's frail it's fragile but it's made
great progress and then on the other
hand there's an attempt to concentrate
all power in other words to make sure
that there is an authoritarian regime
with one person who makes all the
decisions these are two very
contradictory trends and I spent most of
my career really studying countries
where attempts have been made to
concentrate powers in the hands of a
dictator so that really was what
prompted me to write this book I suppose
that when people think back to the 20th
century that are that will be some of
the defining characteristics right so
what is a dictator in its purest form
well this may sound strange but you have
to think of a dictator as developing
against a background of democracy in
other words to put it slightly
differently we live in an age of
democracy in fact since the French and
the American revolutions of the 18th
century we live more or less in an age
of democracy in other words sovereignty
with the collapse of old regimes and
France in particular power is seen to
reside no longer in some sort of
heavenly mandate or in the divine rights
but in the people and people select a
leader through a process of elections of
course this is a very gradually
unfolding age of democracy but it means
that there is a paradox with dictators
they seize power on the one hand but
they must also create the illusion
somehow of popular support and that's
where the cult of personality comes in
that's one of the key focuses of the
book a dictator must on the one hand use
terror you know the secret police
military forces tortures spies the
Praetorian Guard concentration camps but
on the other hand there must also be an
attempt to build up what I call a cult
of personality in other words a dictator
must coerce his people into acclaiming
him he must create the illusion that
people actually support him mmm yeah
you've got to still play the game whilst
also not looking like you're playing a
different game exactly so this is the
great paradox of modern dictators they
all claim to be rather democratic or at
the very least they claim to represent
the true will of the people
yes I understand and it's then a a game
of switching that round how much of this
do you think is very well laid out in
advance from the position of the
dictator and how much of it is us post
hoc rationalization could some of them
have begun with the best ideas of
holding democracy in in mind and then
changed when power became easier for
them to take and advantages became
available I understand the question it's
a very good one you have to bear in mind
that successful dictators are extremely
pragmatic and that hard opportunists
they use whatever comes their way to
their own advantage I'll give you one
example
Hitler carries out a coup in 1923 by
storming a beer hall in Munich it
doesn't succeed but then he turns defeat
into a victory by turning the courtroom
into a propaganda platform with
newspapers reporting everything he says
and then uses his time in prison behind
bars
to write his political autobiography
called
mine [ __ ] and this goes on and on
whenever something happens that might be
seen to go against a dictator many of
them managed to make the very best of it
so they are definitely opportunists who
sees particular you know occasions and
turn it to their advantage but on the
other hand I think it's fair to say that
most of them are pretty convinced that
this sort of that pretty convinced that
power must end up in the hands of one
person all of them express contempt for
what they see as weak wishy-washy
parliamentary democracy
Hitler says so openly the Communists of
course talked about democratic
centralism in other words democracy exec
sir sized by a small committee of people
on behalf of the entire population
[Laughter]
doesn't sound massively like a democracy
that no but of course again it's crucial
to realize that they must invoke the
will of the people they must try to come
up with at least the illusion that
coercion is in effect consent how much
of the rise of a dictator do you think
is the manifestation or the projection
of one person's inner personality their
particular makeup that they have and how
much of it do you think is them chasing
a dream that I guess the difference
between a career and a calling so to
speak as some of them doing it because
they just want power all all costs or do
you think some of them have got a more
meaning more purpose behind that
particular movement yes it's it's the
classic question of power versus
ideology are they there to seek power
and more power all the Gerudo have a
particular vision a particular ideology
that's exactly what I meant yes yes well
it's an old debate and what I'm trying
to show is that all the emphases that
historians have put on ideology I
remember being a student 30 years ago
and I was all about studying the
ideology of Marx's and communism
studying maoism studying Leninism
Stalinism you name it but in the end
what I'm trying to show is that ideology
doesn't really matter all that much to a
dictator what matters is not loyalty to
a Creed's but loyalty to his person
that's what a dictator wishes the
reasons for that are reasonably
straightforward a dictator by definition
is somebody who sees as power
and power has to be maintained power
seized through violence must be
maintained through violence and that can
be a very blunt instrument so it's much
better to try to create loyalty to
enforce it so to speak most of all when
a dictator seizes power he runs the risk
of somebody else doing the same thing to
him in other words there are rivals
somehow waiting in the wings the
prospect of a stab in the back appears
so what do you do to control you in the
court to make sure that your allies or
rivals don't organize a coup against you
as new dictator I think here again
called personality is all-important you
make sure that the people around you
acclaim you they are a based by being
forced to proclaim you as a great leader
and most of all by claiming you as a
great leader allies rivals all of them
have to lie and when they lie when
everybody lies it's very difficult to
find out who actually supports whom so
loyalty is the greatest concern for any
one dictator they're constantly keeping
tabs and the people around them they're
worried about who might betray them yeah
there's a Instagram quote going around
which you probably almost definitely
won't have seen but it's talking about
boys that cheat on girls and it says if
he cheats with you he'll cheat on you
and I think that what that suggests is
past behavior is suggestive of future
behavior and if you've taken power and
you have managed to have a group of
sycophants around you that are
supporting you in this power grab you're
totally right it must be an incredibly
anxious and paranoid environment to be
in is that one person at the top if you
did it what's stopping everybody else
well that's exactly it that's that's
precisely the point is that you want to
have people who were loyal or at this
proclaim themselves to be loyal
you're constantly watching your back
so you really as a dictator you somehow
Teeter between hubris on the one hand
having to make all major decisions under
on your own because you don't trust
anyone else and paranoia and the other
where you see plots around you where you
imagine that there might be enemies when
in fact there might be allies when you
purge friends and foes alike when you
are pretty much on your own at the very
top towering far above all the others
this meta cognizant way of living almost
having two lives your own plus the one
that you're playing with everybody else
plus keeping in mind all of the
interplay the connections between all of
those people and what they genuinely
believe in the games they're playing as
well it must be almost untenable
to live this life without being on the
verge of a breakdown at all times
you only imagine how how testing it must
be I've learned a little bit about
Hitler and I know that he was on all
manner of cocktail of drugs by the end
of World War two in an effort to keep
him up with some maladies that were
perhaps oncoming no matter what but
definitely a lot that we were due to
stress and just him trying to keep all
of this up during your research for the
book did you find any dictators who
seemed to be designed for the job so to
speak they were just made to measure for
the tasks that they had to do and they
took all of this pressure and worry in
their stride well the ones who last tend
to be very gifted we have images in mind
of you know Hitler being a sort of non
person or a grotesque figure but the
truth is that he was extremely
hard-working and it was a very good
orator actor and choreographer he worked
endlessly at building up his party over
the many years in the early 1920s he had
a true instinct for power I was
suspicious of anyone who wasn't true
truly loyal the same could be said of
Stalin an enormous appetite
through work but also great
organizational ability of course some
went too far
miss Shalini spent by some account half
of his time projecting himself as the
omniscient omnipotent dictator of Italy
while also running something like half a
dozen ministries he had time apparently
in the 1930s to even dictate the color
for the cover of a women's magazine
that's a dictatorship that extended all
the way down to daily objects weirdly
enough well that's yeah it goes hand in
hand I suppose this level of neuroticism
must require the dictator to be very
thorough must make them fearful of
relinquishing control and of delegating
but also they have to do that right that
you can't scale this movement without at
least letting some people into the inner
circle yes but it's best to to purge
occasionally which is why it is so very
dangerous to be the number two in a
dictatorial regime in particular
communists ones because there's always a
suspicion that number from on the part
of number one that number two wants to
take his place I understand so in the
career of a dictator
where are the major stumbling blocks
where do they mostly fail we're talking
about how to be a dictator and if we've
got our imaginary our imaginary dictator
in the audience who's listening what
does he need to do first well there is
really no magic list it's on the one
hand these dictators have an awful lot
in common although you will always find
an exception to the rule but on the
other hand they're extremely individual
and you can see why conditions very
enormous Lee from a reason that we
developed modern country
like Germany in the early 1930s to a
very impoverished mainly rural country
like Haiti in the 1960s under Papa Doc
Duvalier but the conditions very
enormous Lee so I guess one of the very
attributes of a dictator is to
understand local culture extremely well
and be able to use it in order to become
a dictator if you would take Stalin and
take him out of the Soviet Union and
somehow make him run the People's
Republic of China for a while it would
not work these are individuals who are
very closely linked to that that the
times and circumstances of their
countries they were made to measure in
that way I suppose very much and they
also made themselves to measure they
were not afraid of turning ideal
ideology on its head take for instance
Marxist ideology it says that there will
be a world revolution carried out by the
workers but now in 1927 takes off to the
countryside and embraces the very
peasants that are derided by Orthodox
Marxism in other words he makes villages
you know the the focal point of this
revolution turning it upside down kim
il-song North Korea very much the same
thing and braces Marxism but then after
a while comes up with the theory of
self-reliance where people who are
self-reliant can somehow achieved the
revolution without any regard to the
so-called material circumstances which
is you know the bedrock of Marxist
theory in fact by 1972 Kim Bo song in
North Korea has virtually written
Marxism out of the Constitution to even
study Marx or angles is seen as a sign
of lack of loyalty to the leader himself
so in other words under Kim il-sung one
reads kim il-song under Mao you read now
under Stalin
they've transcended what they were
before quite quite that's interesting so
it's recently brought up topic with
regards to North Korea and the movements
that it's making at the moment so why
don't you tell us some of the things
that you learned about Kim il-sung
during your research I'm fascinated to
learn about how North Korea got to the
particular approach to politics that it
has now now Kimmel song is quite an
extraordinary figure because he is
somebody who is pretty much imposed by
the Soviet Union on an unwilling
population yet within several years he
manages to play to great backers and
superpowers against each other to obtain
more independence namely the People's
Republic of China that helps Kimball's
song a start his war of unification
against South Korea in the early 1950s
and the Soviet Union that installed him
in the first place so within years by
1956 he's managed to play the one
against the other has managed to purge
all those who were loyal to Moscow or to
Beijing and install his own people by
than he tolls the country in whirlwind
visits to factories to the countryside
dispensing his advice making himself
visible literally to millions his
portrait is everywhere his words are in
every newspapers committed to memory by
ordinary people by the 1960s and 70s
family members up to a good dozen of
them are in key positions of power so
from there onwards you can see that this
will become a dynasty when he passes
away in the early 1990s his son takes
over and keeps all the attributes of
power namely fear terror on the one hand
and a an extravagant cult of personality
on the other it blasts to this very day
is it common for dictators to keep it in
the family it doesn't seem that way but
my my understanding isn't so much
certainly with North Korea it does but
has that been a tactic used elsewhere
no again it all depends on circumstances
and the dictators who succeed so to
speak by that I mean they die in their
own bed as opposed to for as opposed to
Mussolini yeah the ones who succeed are
extremely pragmatic so if you can't
trust anyone
it might be a good idea to have a family
member there but it doesn't always work
like that Mao tried with the nephew but
it backfired rather badly another
example besides kim il-song who
successfully installed his own son would
be Papa Doc who I mentioned earlier on
or Juve ali-a he manages to install his
own son in 1972 when he dies so that
regime will last for another good decade
or so
but the truth is succession is always a
great issue for dictators the reason is
very simple in a democracy it's not so
much that people get voted in they get
voted out if you're a dictator
there's no point at which you can leave
without fear for your life it's very
difficult to just say ah I think I've
been a good dictator for 20 years now
let me get back to my stamp collection
and go fishing in the countryside
there's no general retirement plan once
you've chosen the profession of dictator
is there precisely is interesting so I
know that we've got some examples from
Ethiopia as well I didn't know the
background was so dictatorial what's the
story behind that
well again an empire Ethiopia Haile
Selassie and then a famine that very
much prompts a popular uprising in 1974
a number of soldiers seized power one of
them called Mengistu gradually
eliminates all others and becomes
dictator he manages to eliminate all the
others because he's extremely
hardworking he's very good at reading of
the people and he's more determined and
ruthless than all the others one of the
very first victims is general man and
Dom who was actually the man who took
Mengistu under his wing when he was
still young something is to sends
soldiers to kill him several years after
the 1974 revolution making sure that the
very man who Wallis adopted him and
became his mentor is eliminated he does
so with others to that big committee
called the derg doug de RG means
committee in amharic was established by
about 120 people by 1976 no more than 60
are left people are literally carried
out from the imperial palace the grand
palace that he occupies after having
been shot with a gun that is not a very
good party
I don't want to go through you know no
the Emperor himself Haile Selassie's dis
is deposed locked up and allegedly
throttled to death man gives to has a
barrage in the Grand Palace which he
occupies underneath his office and then
places his desk right above his corpse
somehow absorbing the charisma of the
Emperor Wow
that is that's one way to make sure that
he's dead
I suppose so one of the topics that I
know that you covered was to do with
parades and me thinking about
dictatorships you have these images of
huge armies and these massive shows of
force whether some of these that were
particularly massive that you looked up
well they're all they're all massive and
the whole point of a parade of course is
to display your military might
the world is astonished when on 20 April
1939
the the formal corporal called Adolf
Hitler acts like an emperor sitting on
the gilded chair on a on a raged day as
reviewing the mighty war machine he is
assembled but what you have to bear in
mind is that it's also meant to be a
display by ordinary people of their love
for the dictator so in the case of Haiti
for instance occasionally people are
rounded up with lorries very much
brought to the capital port-au-prince
roads are locked off they're not fed
they're not given anything to drink and
then they must parade in front of the
presidential palace and cheer their
leader chant the slogans and put on a
happy face they must quite literally
create the illusion of consent so of
parades are very much part of that cult
of personality where people are if you
wish condemned to perpetual enthusiasm
yeah again doesn't sound like your good
afternoon
to me I don't wanna be in the palace
where I get shot I don't want to be on
the parade row don't get any drink or
water it doesn't sound like a very happy
place to be have there been many
dictatorships where you would have said
the population had a good time well this
is the great thing about dictators is
that the population always looks very
happy they're they're cheering
the leader they're chanting slogans they
put on happy faces and when the
dictators die in the case of Mao in 1976
and a case of Kindles song in 94 people
seem to cry in career they pound the
chest to rip off their clothes you know
or shake a fist at the sky and feigned
rage but you don't know who believes
what are they really upset or not in
some cases people will pretend to cry in
public but once they are back home they
will open a good bottle of wine and
celebrate very cool
[Laughter]
yeah it is crazy I saw a vice
documentary about where they've gone
into North Korea and this soap opera
style actor actor ship I suppose as
people were driving around and they were
going into restaurants where there was
huge swathes of serving staff and food
laid out but the only customers were
them and then that's exactly it they go
a school and speak to the children and
the children would have oddly clear
responses and so with the parents that
sounded almost as if they'd been
scripted and again it's that that show
of unification isn't it both inward and
outward well that's exactly it in in a
good dictatorship dictators are great
actors and people are great actors as
Adolf Hitler said in an unguarded moment
he considered himself to be Europe's
greatest performer but ordinary people
too are great actors they must learn how
to jump to attention chant the slogans
cheer the leader and if they don't
they're as being fined imprisoned
occasionally shot
occasionally shot well at least I've got
a chance of not being shot this time No
so as we move towards the modern day of
politics how do you think this last
hundred years history of prominent
dictators has shaped how we look at
politics now and also how political
figures nowadays are behaving well
remember what I said in the beginning
you could summarize the 20th century as
two opposite trends one trend is towards
the separation of powers and the
building of an accountable civil society
with checks and balances and an
independent judicial system rule of law
and the other one is a trend who is the
concentration of power in the hands of
other one party or one person and one
party always ends up being one person so
if you look at it from a very broad
perspective then quite clearly one trend
has been on the up and the other one has
not quite vanished but very much been on
the losing end of history to put it
differently I think we tend to
underestimate how far we have come we
tend to overestimate how many dictators
there still are and what threats there
might be to democracy we hear terms of a
coup or a dictator or a cult of
personality used in the case of
democratically elected people for the
recent main porch or Trump sometimes
even the Pope but quite clearly there
was a time in the 1930s in the 1950s in
the 1970s when half the planet was run
by rather nasty dictators now remember
that even in Europe up till 1973 there
was no talk about Western democracy as
in Western Europe because it was only
the northwest of Europe in Portugal yet
Salazar in Spain you had Franco in
Greece you had a number of nasty
generals
it was all alone only with the carnation
revolution of Portugal and the death of
Franco that all of a sudden one could
talk about Western Europe as being
democratic never mind the rest of the
world and then you have the collapse of
the Soviet Union all of it in 91 92
we've come a very long way it's not to
say that we shouldn't be vigilant do you
think it would be realistic for a
dictator to rise to power
now it's bloody hard work and I would
say that as a result of all the
dictatorships we had in the 20th century
it is extremely difficult because with
every dictator that has been defeated
democracy has been reinforced has been
fortified that separation of powers has
become more entrenched the separation of
power the checks and balances have
become far more sophisticated so
it's difficult it's not to say but we
don't have dictatorships clearly there
is one in the People's Republic of China
and clearly there's one in northern
Korea and other countries but overall I
would think it's pretty much for losing
back yeah you're gonna be fighting
against the tide a little bit aren't you
it's very interesting what you say about
this cult of personality and these these
terms that are thrown around these slurs
or labels or sometimes just throwaway
lines people are constantly looking for
the New World Order
there's the accusations of the Queen
being a lizard person or Donald Trump
being part of some may Sounion Lodge
that's actually trying you know is this
is this people chasing down a narrative
which has kind of been and gone a little
bit now
well it trivializes what happened to
hundreds of millions of ordinary people
throughout the 20th century in the
People's Republic of China under Mao
alone tens of millions of people over
starved beaten work to death the number
of victims under Stalin tis also
enormous not to mention I love Hitler so
well we use terms like a coup or
dictator or called a personality for
people have been more or less
democratically elected in the 21st I
think there's a danger of losing any
sense of perspective that's happening
with everything at the moment though
right the people are throwing around the
word Nazi like it's calling someone tall
like it's just a common word to call
someone a accusing Trump of being a
white supremacist and he said a lot of
things that I find pretty terrible to
agree with but there's a big jump
between what he said in being a white
supremacist indeed if you want to know
whether it was a dictatorship or not I
would say travel to the country you are
interested in and find out if you can
save something negative about the man in
charge
well I would say there's plenty in the
United States that is critical of Trump
is that the canary in the coal mine
pretty much if you don't want to go to
the United States
why don't you travel to the People's
Republic of China and see if you can say
something negative about Xi Jinping
I would say good luck with that one what
do you think would happen I think you'll
be arrested and put away well is that
that's how quickly they're going to
respond how would they find out would it
be somebody else another member of the
general public yes you'll be denounced
try publishing something be very
difficult there's no freedom of speech
there's no freedom of publication what's
happening in China at the moment to me
just seems it seems so alien given the
current makeup of the world in the 21st
century well that's one of the points I
I was trying to make earlier on it
resembles a you know good old-fashioned
dictatorship but they're running out of
time they seem out of place yeah they do
don't they it's this archaic oh and and
but is the pressure ever going to come
from within with these modern
dictatorships as I can't think of
another name for them
these modern dictatorships is the
uprising going to come from within or is
it going to be the job of another
government to step in and say look this
is this is no longer allowed well you
never know but generally it comes from
within you know all these people who
have been such good actors all of a
sudden will drop the pretense and spawn
you had causes this happened in Romania
and the Ceausescu you can see how under
21st of December 1989 he gives his
speech from the balcony of the Party
headquarters and bit-by-bit
the people who were supposed to be
cheering him start shouting back and
booing him you could see almost a minute
where this is obviously televised you
could see almost the minute where the
fear breaks down and
Shizuku looks at the crowd utterly
stupefied that what is happening three
days later he's shot Wow yeah it's it's
interesting to have that those two
realities existing at the same time the
one that is being dictated and the one
which is actually happening so one of
the things that you've kept on
mentioning is the charisma of the
leaders the fact that they often great
speakers or orator z' in the case of
Hitler obviously today we are seeing
these techniques and these skills highly
valued
you've got television debates you've got
social media and always-on communication
do you think that the tactics and the
techniques of the 20th century are being
used at any point right now well you
know dictators are always good and
exploiting the latest technology
Alif Hitler was very skilled
broadcasting his speeches he worked at
his broadcasting skills he was a very
good orator as well Mussolini too tried
to use television and radio to make sure
that his presence was felt and every
square there would be public
loudspeakers and cities Mobile once
taken to the countryside so today of
course the Internet is the latest
technology and indeed certainly North
Korea and the People's Republic of China
you can see how it is extremely
carefully monitored we thought for a
while here in our democracies that the
internet would be a tool of liberation
it turns out as the exact opposite when
it's used by a dictatorship it's very
your well Yin isn't it indeed yeah I
wonder what it would be like to live in
in that environment it's the same to me
as saying imagine what it's like to live
on the moon because it will be so many
fundamentals of the way that you operate
in society on your own
at business at work I'm a small business
owner and how I would operate at work
would be completely changed if I was in
China I'd probably have a government
representative either in my company or
constantly checking in it seems so alien
well it is alien it's a different
civilization altogether it's a clash of
civilizations I would have a party
secretary in my history department who
decides what kind of research I can do
what I should teach and who we should
invite there'd be a party member at
every level there would be no freedom of
assembly no freedom of speech no freedom
of religion except for the religion
tolerated by the regime and you know no
no freedom of association either so it's
it's just an alien regime which is why
you see what is happening in Hong Kong
today a very backwards almost barbaric
regime that simply is incapable of
administering a very sophisticated city
like Hong Kong if you cross the border
from Hong Kong into the People's
Republic of China it's a different
culture it's a different place it's a
different planet
and we tend to forget you know how alien
it can be mm-hmm
is there a on pretty much every
dictatorship is there a limited lifespan
it's so volatile and there's so many
ways it can go wrong that inevitably
it's going to happen or could you see a
world in which you get this 1984 style
authoritarian regime that rises to the
top and holds its power some of them
last for a very long time the Soviet
Union would be one example but still
just over 70 years the People's Republic
of China will be celebrating its 70
years on the 1st of October next month
they rarely last much longer so good
luck Frank today's been absolutely
fantastic
opened my eyes to a lot hopefully we
haven't inspired any would-be dictators
but we'll look out
we'll have to who will have to wait and
see link to how to be a dictator we'll
be in the show notes below highly advise
that you go and check it out if anyone
wants to read more of your work or find
out some more information where should
they head online Frank amazon.com UK
that's the it's the hub for everything
do we think Amazon might be a
dictatorship I think it might be no I
doubt it
Jeff Bezos Jeff Bezos might be living a
double life you never know if we get any
if you have any Amazon workers that are
listening feel free to give me a message
and let me know if Jeff Bezos is
actually a tyrant in waiting but no
Frank
today's been fantastic thank you so much
for your time thank you
[Music]
you